look at this with no ged there how is
that not
advocating dropping out of high school
sup sup welcome to the 10 million dollar
studio i'm the broke internet detective
ready to talk to you guys today about
the problem of high school dropouts
flexing on everybody okay it's
an issue it's a big issue today we're
talking about wait
whoa whoa wait you're saying hey who are
you coffee zilla to be
hating sorry sorry hold on hold on let
me let me get my uh
social proof in the background oh do you
believe me now
suddenly i look a lot more credible huh
how did i afford this lambo just wait
till the end of the video
i'll show you guys i want to talk about
this we we've had a bit of an
issue okay and it all stems from all
these guys saying for years
that you know oh college hey you don't
need college dude college
is for losers and a natural extension of
that is like if
you know if college isn't useful that
there's
nothing more useless than high school
and as a result we have all these 17
year olds
18 year olds dropping out of school
now let's uh take a look at some of them
okay how dropping out of my school made
me a millionaire let's
take a quick listen together we were
eating in that restaurant right behind
me
and i looked across the table and i said
dad school is stupid
it's a waste of my time the teachers
don't get me i'm not gonna go to college
okay and i grab this and i hand it to
him and it wasn't the first time he
heard me make that speech so
bro first of all yikes this is not
how the story of steve jobs started but
the video is not about
a failure or anything like that it's
really about
nice cars about being a success
having a tesla guys yeah so of course
this guy uh
sells courses that's how all of this
works
how can they afford to do this well can
they afford a tesla
they sell you a course here's another
one day in the life
of an 18 year old high school dropout
how do these people
upload this stuff with no sense of irony
like flex
i just feel bad for kids who think this
is like real like
this baller so the first 20 or 30
minutes of my morning
always consists of me literally getting
up i'll quickly check my phone for any
like urgent texts
um and then i'll go take it by the way
sorry sorry let me preface something
okay i have no problem with anyone being
a high school dropout
right it happens people can be very
successful with a high school dropout
i want to clarify that this is only
about people flexing their life
on social media to try to get you to
sign up for a course that i have a
problem with
this guy jacob that you're seeing right
now his name is make money with jacob
online okay and of course uh he sells a
course
researching if i should drop out phyllis
[ __ ] righteous
sister figuring out you don't need
school for real estate
and then he misspelled estate okay got
it and 90
of millionaires made their money doing
it drop out time
yeah yeah this is this is not good and
look it's not even that i want to get on
my moral high horse here
okay right i just get annoyed when i see
these guys
tell me i just think it's funny to call
them out yeah the money gun
yeah you're a loser anybody who owns a
money gun
instant l it's a new breed of
entrepreneur out here it's oh it's not
an entrepreneur it's like a fake
it's a facsimile of an entrepreneur
that's honestly what it is it's like
the new breed is like the appearance
almost like what hollywood
thinks rich people act like or sort of
what poor people think rich people act
like which is really funny
that's what's being flexed now now
probably my favorite of all these guys
is hayden bowles
okay because he's got a video called
driving my lamborghini to the high
school i dropped out of
reactions hey how many views does this
have on it four million people thinking
wow hayden cool i want to be just like
you hayden
guys you're gonna drop out and be
working at mcdonald's unless you can
convince enough idiots
to uh sign up for your course in which
case you'll be like hayden bowles
now one thing i want to say up front is
all these guys to be fair to them they
all say i don't advocate dropping out of
high school the last thing is
i do not condone dropping out at all
should you drop out of high school i
immediately yell no
no no don't do it right so all of them
say the exact they're all carbon copies
of each other right
but then what do they actually do in
their thing i mean whether they are
intentionally doing this or not all they
do is
flex dropping out of high school as if
it's the greatest thing
ever because they go around in uh their
lamborghini again we're going back to
the driving my lamborghini to high
school that i was in
and this guy i'll wait till you guys see
the bumper sticker on this thing
look at this they're personal to me with
no ged there
how is that not advocating dropping out
of high school i mean it's like amazing
to me all these guys are like no no i
would never
i would never advocate for dropping out
of high school but you want to learn to
make a million bucks with me
hayden balls hey dude hey shopify
you want to join my course because if
you want to go to your high school
and and flex a lambo in front of it
that's how you do it baby
you join my course there and i'm
actually i found one of my
old old yearbooks i can't imagine
something more cringy than this but i
know there's so many people who see this
and go wow that's
how cool is that so it was kind of a
unique situation because this school
ninth grade which is normally high
school is still in the middle school
because the high school side of it was
too small
so i only actually got one year of like
being in the high school before i
dropped out because i left at the end of
10th grade
so yeah we're gonna get an instagram
photo i'm thinking
kind of like right here how is this not
promoted i don't understand it
all these guys they flex to get you to
buy their course and they go i don't
advocate
hey i want to be clear about something i
don't advocate dropping out of
high school guys it'd be like if i
flexed all the time like hey look how
much money look at the money i'm making
with youtube
okay first of all i'm in debt let's be
honest but if i did that
and then go hey guys i don't advocate
joining youtube but
it's easy hey but watch me drive my
youtube lambo
to school watch me drive this bad boy to
school
i mean it's bad enough when people who
had money flexed on you there was a time
where that was like seen as
not cool like you just don't do it you
don't flex money
but there's this weird instagram culture
where not only is that okay
it's like the way you make money the way
you make money if you're broke
is pretend to have money and flex it on
instagram as a high school dropout
and then you get a bunch of kids to bind
your course it's so pathetic and i want
to call it out
dude if you see this kind of stuff on
youtube or instagram call it out
you know they're not making the money
they say they're making you know they're
not doing
what they say they're doing this is not
how rich people act
warren buffett doesn't have to tell you
he's rich warren buffett doesn't
drive to his high school in a lambo
right who would do that
mark cuban elon musk who are like these
celebrity rich people
not even someone as shameless as kevin
o'leary would do that so
that's basically it i just wanted to
show you this today it's super cringe
i can't imagine something less cool than
that like literally going to your eyes
will be like look at the lambo i bought
guys haha
no ged anyways that's it don't believe
the liars
don't believe people flexing on you just
unfollow
them that's what i do i feel like all of
it can honestly be summed up in this
picture right here
like what's happening i'm influencing
you how does it feel
kind of bad like share and subscribe for
more
that's basically it stop it i'll see you
next time
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick
trying to sell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee